- [Voiceover] So, the other
day I was talking to my friend
about what our families
eat around Christmastime.
My family eats, like, tamales,
pozole, chocolate Abuelita.
And she was like, nah, it's
all about Ibarra, homie.
Nah, fool, it's all about Abuelita.
Ibarra!
Abuelita!
So we pit the two Mexican
hot chocolate icons
in a battle to the death
to settle this matter
once and for all.
Who will win? Let's find out.
(jazzy music)
- Well it's either 50-50.
You're either an Abuelita
fan or you're an Ibarra fan.
- I like Ibarra.
- And I grew up with Abuelita.
- I'm team Abuelita.
- Abuelita, and I feel like I've seen this
in more households.
- What is the packaging the exact same?
- Abuelita looks like she has good chisme.
- Made in Glendale. So.
- Yeah this one's made in
México, homie, like let's go!
(boxing bell dings)
- It's really good though.
- Smells really good.
- Like it smells a little
bit like a doughnut.
- Smells like cheese.
- Chin, ching-ching.
- I feel loved.
- I feel like I just got a hug.
- Oh, I like that! My
glasses are all steamy.
- Shoutout to whoever made this.
- Get a conchita and
just go to town with it.
- It's subtle.
- It's nice.
- I was, I guess I was
expecting something stronger.
- I'm not going to say anything
until I try the other one.
(boxing bell dings)
- You can smell more spices.
- This one definitely has more of a kick.
- Did you taste it?
- Oh, I'm sorry!
- God dammit!
- This tastes more like the real deal,
the one with the cinnamon.
- This one tastes more real.
- I know I haven't tasted this before.
- I've tasted this. This is
like spot on, my childhood.
(boxing bell dings)
- I'm double fisting here
because they're both great.
- This one, I can, I feel
like I can taste the Nestle.
- Nestle made this for people like me
that don't do spicy.
- I feel like this one
is one that you can give
like little kids with cookies,
and it's like really
pleasant and comforting.
- Yeah.
- This is like a more adult one.
- I choose choice number one.
- The one I like more is Ibarra.
- Oh as much as I love abuelas everywhere,
I gotta go with the one
that I think is Ibarra.
- Because of that huge nostalgia bomb,
I'm gonna go with this one right here.
- Probably take number two.
- I like me some, what
I think is Abuelita.
- This one, which I think is Ibarra,
I would drink again and again and again.
- Oh (beep) Well, I like this one.
But I really hope that this is Abuelita.
(boxing bell rings)
- Are we right? Am I wrong?
- We're wrong, aren't we?
- Boom!
- I was wrong, and I'm
happy that I'm wrong.
- What up homie, I'm a Mexican!
And my tongue is, too!
- Abuelita is kinda like your friend that
gets like the record deal
and is all of a sudden
she's like famous and
too good for everybody.
- Imma just mix them, shit.
They're gonna be mixed like me.
- They're both hot chocolate.
I'd probably just have both.
(jazzy music)